hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today
is the world's best female
ultrarunner straight up and when it
comes to the really long stuff
races in excess of 200 miles she is
arguably
the best period a two-time ultrarunner
of the year named one of the 50
fittest athletes in the world by sports
illustrated courtney dewalter
beat everybody men included at the moab
which she won by a staggering 10
hours and at the big dog backyard ultra
where she clocked an astonishing
283 miles she also won the women's
division at the western states 100
and utmb the two most prestigious ultras
in the world and of course many other
victories along the way
courtney is a humble master of mental
grit
and boundary busting physical prowess
but she's also just super fun to be with
so please hit that subscribe button and
let's get after it this is me
and the great courtney dewalter
it's so nice to meet you thank you for
coming out to do this i i really
appreciate it i've been looking forward
to this for a very long time yeah thank
you
how are you feeling these days good yeah
yeah i'm excited the
snow is starting to melt in colorado so
well it's june
i hope yeah it takes a while yeah
so it's getting warm out there you're
totally healed up after the
colorado trail bronchitis episode
yeah totally healed up i um probably
only had a couple months where i noticed
that in my lungs last year and then um
yeah it was kind of like all green
lights once they revealed
and you're getting ready to tackle a
pretty
um auspicious double you're gonna do
utmb in august or in hard rock 100 in
july first right and then right on the
back of that a month later
utmb yeah yeah 200 mile races
um it'll be really cool short ones yeah
yeah uh i don't i mean it's just a fun
challenge i think they're like
six weeks apart um so i have no idea
what the
time between will look like i think just
kind of figure that out as i go and
um try to be ready to rumble at both of
them
when you say you have no idea that's
sort of
revealing in terms of your approach to
your training right
like you're this intuitive when it comes
to
how you approach your routine
correct yeah there's no plan that's so
crazy you literally do you wake up in
the morning and then make the decision
or do you plan the day before do you
plan a week
i mean you must have a general idea
other than like okay
you know i typically put in 100 miles a
week
you must have a little bit more of a
specific sense of what you're trying to
accomplish like walk me through this so
i
i better understand because you play it
off like
with this very aw shucks you know
disposition
but i know there's more going on nope
it's all
awesome um no i
so every day i do wake up and after
drinking coffee
i'll figure out what i'm doing that day
there's no like
uh there's no plan going into a week
what the days might hold
but i will know when races are
and i will know like when i can go
kind of hog wild with training and when
i should you know
pull in the reins a little bit and be
smart because there's a race coming up
or
i should focus on something specific
like climbing in the mountains or
trying to run a little bit faster so
i'll know those things it's not
totally winging it in that way but every
single day
it's deciding how i feel physically and
mentally to
determine what the run will be is there
any
scheduling of like okay on these days
i typically go longer and these are more
tempo days or technique days or
speed focus days not really you just go
out and go
long pretty much and just switch up the
terrain based upon what you're training
for
yeah a lot of the days are just long
days
but i'll do intervals and stuff i
sometimes won't even
know when those are going to happen once
i'm on the run
there's just a few routes that i'll do
where
there's a hill that i really like to do
intervals on so if i get to that spot on
the route
and i feel it then i'll pop some into it
and if not then i just carry on
and does that come into play like you it
doesn't appear that you've ever
over trained right do you know when to
back off so you don't kind of
tip over into that terrain where you're
gonna wear yourself down too much and
not be able to recover
is that all on feel as well or have you
just not you have such a capacity you're
such a workhorse that you've never
hit that place
uh no i've made mistakes for sure or
um just tried to keep loading it on but
i think that's part of what i like about
not having a plan
is that i get to just figure it out by
making those mistakes
so run myself into a ground one week and
realize like
that was a few too many miles so now i
can
go from there and try and you know hone
in on what i'm doing a little bit
and no coach input no
no no i did though i mean i grew up with
fantastic coaches
so in high school and in college i um
worked with some
amazing people and i think like they
showed me all the types of workouts that
you can be doing it wasn't for ultra
running but
um like i'll still draw on that and
and use some of what i learned from them
to decide what i might do
what's interesting about that is you
have a science background you are a
science teacher
right so why not
avail yourself of like the science like
like oh
periodization seems to work or maybe
you're already doing that i don't know
but you know there's a lot of athletes
and you see this
much more in in track and field or in
triathlon than you do
in trail running where people get really
into the graphs
you know and the heart rate and the
power output and
you know all these all these data points
around sleep performance and all of that
and and you know get mired in in that
in terms of trying to figure out how to
crack the code on training
yeah that's exactly what i don't want
right
in your scientific approach yeah because
why not
i i mean i'm having so much fun with
how it is right now and um i don't
have a reason to change it i also uh
i don't know i think that without a plan
i do much better
actually listening to my body so i pay
more attention if there's no
schedule and there's no workout written
down then i can really tune in and
uh react you know if it's an off day
then
i don't do a workout you have no problem
like pulling the plug yeah and i don't
feel any guilt because there was
nothing planned anyways i don't know
um because i haven't had a plan or a
coach in ultra running but i feel like i
could get like really attached to it if
i had it
and then disregard you know any symptoms
or signs that i should
change course hmm right thinking
oh i need to accomplish this because the
coach said this is what i need to do and
then that
that ends up corrupting this sort of
perfect situation that you have for
yourself
it's not perfect but i uh
i think if it's fun and i'm enjoying
every day and i'm still
like i'm still getting in the miles and
the workouts that i'd like then
i'm gonna stick with it for now i can
see tons of benefits of having a coach
uh but for now i would keep it this way
yeah it's working
right don't mess with it uh i i do think
that
that that happiness piece is is
a big part of your secret sauce like
you're able to find
the joy in all facets of this and that
seems to be like
fuel right a lot of people in in this
subculture
they you know um are powered by oh
it's the grit and how hard it is and i'm
gonna really embrace the suffering and
and not from a victimhood place but but
kind of like a more hardcore
relationship to the difficulty of
completing these races and the training
that goes into them
and you're just having fun like all the
time like billy yang is here and
and i texted him the other day and i
told him you were coming and he's like
oh that's so great 100
approval rating in the trail community
like there's nobody that doesn't love
courtney and no matter how hard the race
is
or whatever you're enduring internally
you always have a smile on your face you
always have a moment to give a high five
to a little kid or to say
a nice thing to a volunteer on the
course
and that takes you know a conscious
effort like there's a certain
disposition that you have that
seems to be unwavering well thank you
i uh it's we're so lucky to be able to
choose something like this to do with
our time
so i think if you're not having fun with
it then
um i don't know maybe reconsider some
things
yeah but fun
isn't i mean it is fun and everything
about
trail running is awesome but for a lot
of people
fun isn't in like the top five uh
adjectives you know
how they describe their participation in
this so how do you keep that in check
it's just
it's just natural to you right it must
be in minnesota
[Laughter]
i like how you don't seem to overthink
things too much
you know i think that's also there's
there's a lesson in that
right like you just you're having fun
you go out you train really hard
you go in with a smile you're a
competitor
but in the in your in your kind of list
of priorities like
keeping it fun keeping it light staying
present with what you're doing
seems to you know be the priority
absolutely
yeah yeah i'm sure every interview you
do
they ask you you know how come you're so
much better than everyone else
right and you always have a very
diplomatic uh response to that
but i don't want to let you off the hook
on this
like somebody who's crushed it you know
there's these famous stories about you
winning the moab
240 by 10 hours and all these other you
know races that you've
destroyed everybody men included um
you seem to sort of shrug it off but
you must think at some point like how
come
this is the case like what is when you
go to sleep at night
do you does it ever like do you ever
ponder like what is the differentiator
between you
and your fellow competitors
no i don't
oh man i mean i think
like everyone can be pushing themselves
so
i don't i can't compare like what it's
like in someone else's body or head
and then what's going on in mine so i
have no idea
but um i do know like
i enjoy that place that we get to go to
in these ultras where
it hurts really bad i think that's
pretty cool
and uh i mean that's gotta help like not
avoiding it but
wanting to get to it has gotta
be like factored in there somehow
yeah sure
okay let's go a little bit deeper
tell me tell me a little bit more about
what that
is when you reach that point or that
limit or
that place where you feel like you can't
put one foot in front of the other like
what is the what is the like the
the lesson that you find for yourself in
that
so i call it the pain cave that place
and uh i guess like probably four or
five
years ago i viewed the pain cave as like
this place that you should try to put
off as long as possible
in a race like make your pain cave be as
far away from you as you can and if you
arrive to it then you just sit in it and
you try and survive
the pain cave um but in the past couple
years
i mean it's just a mindset right it's
like all in our heads
this thing and uh in the past couple
years it's been
the place i want to get to so like
changing it to a place
where i get to celebrate that i made it
there and then
that's where the work actually happened
so
making the pain cave bigger is how i
view it instead of
like pushing the pain cave away and i
think
i mean our minds are so powerful so even
just like changing the storyline
makes it a whole different game right
so what is the story that you like what
is the the script that you flip when
you're
when you're in that headspace and it's
getting really hard
yeah it's like perfect this is what we
wanted like
now we get to actually do the hard work
of making the cave bigger
and so it's like picturing a chisel and
just like
making tunnels in my pain cave in my
brain
right you actually visualize that
yeah i'm super visual yeah yeah
i like that it makes it very visceral
and like real if you can
it's not just a mantra and mantras are
great i'm sure you have mantras
but actually creating that
three-dimensional image
in your mind yeah yeah and all i mean
it's just telling myself a different
story about that place where
it hurts so bad you know where before it
was like
surviving it and now it's like this is
so cool we made it here and now
we we work yeah it's funny i've
i've been doing this podcast thing for a
couple years at this point
and i've had a lot of people on who have
done hard things and i have
psychologists and psychiatrists and
mindset experts and everybody kind of
comes to the table and they're like this
is how you do it and it's like
step one two three and like when your
mind does this and you're just like well
i just you know like
you just like it's very um refreshing
because what it does is it dispels this
myth that it has to be
complicated or that there is a right or
a wrong way like you're just
embracing life in all its colors and
have figured out this thing that works
for you
but it's welcoming to people because
because you're saying
like look you know i'm doing this you
can do this too like there's a
there's a um what's the right word
uh i mean welcoming to repeat myself
i think is what it is like you're
creating space for other people
to see greater possibility in themselves
because of that relatability
well thank you yeah it's very kind yeah
no i think it's powerful it's really
powerful
um in the in the equation of
of mind versus body like how do you
think about
that like how much of it is physical
prowess versus
mental grit it's both for sure and i
think
in an ultra it trades back and forth
between the two so like maybe for a
while your physical has to pull
more of the weight um because it can
and then if that's giving out maybe the
mental takes over
for a while so i think they they tag
each other out
back and forth where you need them for
sure like physically it's hard to
run this far but mentally
you can like move your feet much farther
than you think
right yeah ultimately i think the
differentiator is in
the mental game because everybody
especially at the elite level
is training really hard and there's only
so much training that you can do before
you get injured or you over train right
so when you toe the line at the starting
line
you can be assured that everybody who's
a threat to your
you know dominance has put in the work
that you've put in right
so the person who's going to win it's
going to come down to
who's going to who's going to crack
mentally when the tuff gets going
yeah yeah and like who can
you know problem solve efficiently or uh
not let problems that come up ruffle
their feathers too much
i think that's huge in ultras yeah just
being able to maintain that positive
disposition
yeah rather than oh no this is terrible
right awesome
this is what it's about right exactly
[Laughter]
how do you keep a smile on your face and
tell jokes and do all that stuff when
you're so freaking exhausted
jokes help everything yeah yeah
that's part of the strategy sneaky
yeah i'm actually really bad at telling
jokes so
it's like a mental game for myself to
try and tell a joke with the correct
punch line
so maybe it's like a making sure that
you're still losing vanity check yeah
um it is so interesting that equation
between mental and physical like we were
chatting before the podcast i was in
utah uh the last couple days i joined
the iron cowboy for day 91 on his
conquer 100 insanity quest so cool
and that guy is a master of of the
mental game
and he's somebody who's so physically
strong but also somebody whose mental
game
so far exceeds his physical capabilities
that this guy's willing to just
completely break his body like he will
not crack
there's no way he's gonna give up for a
physical reason
his mental his mental game is so strong
that he will literally run his body into
the ground
and do irreparable damage before he
pulls out of this thing
which is worrisome i think but also
impressive
and one of the things i noticed i i
walked a marathon with him the other day
is just his ability to remain
positive under all circumstances and
there's so many people that are
congregated around him and they all want
a piece of him and he
makes time for every single one of those
people and then finishes the day
and always like spontaneously delivers
some
impassioned inspirational speech you
know for everybody to take home with
them
yeah and the kind of presence of mind
that you have to have to do that
i think is really the differentiator and
what you do like the way that you carry
yourself
as simple like what you do is the way
you do it is different but
the in the venn diagram like it's that
positivity piece i think
that is really powerful yeah well thank
you
so what's his mood like as he's walking
well you don't know what's going on
internally because he refuses
to say anything negative okay so no
matter what's happening
he's like it's awesome this is great
yeah you know it's it's this is like
we're you know we're just
we're just doing it man you know and you
know like
i'm like are you okay i think he is like
he he seems genuinely in a good place
right now and he's had his ups and downs
of course over the last
93 days or whatever it is yeah and he
will have completed it
um hopefully by the time this goes up
but it's
you know there's there's so much to
learn by just observing somebody like
that
yeah for sure what you project out i
mean
hearing it like you're hearing it in
your head but when you say it out loud
it can
make a huge difference right it makes it
real yeah or more real at least
i've told so my husband is um often the
crew at my races and
beforehand we're always like i don't
know i tell them just don't ask me how
it's going
during because if it's going bad i don't
need to tell you that
like you know and if it's going good we
don't need to say that either let's just
like
carry forward right right right because
it does nothing to
tell you how bad my legs hurt right now
is that
outlook something you've always had or
something that you've developed or
or learned to
not want to share how it's going no no
no just just being hot like
understanding the power of positivity
and you know
and having that kind of fortitude around
protecting
you know um your state of mind
like is that a minnesota thing is that a
is that the way your parents raised you
is that something you learned as an
athlete
in high school or is that just courtney
yeah
i feel like ultrarunning has taught a
lot of it to me
um when you're in those 100 or 200 mile
races you can
learn a lot about what your brain can do
and what's helpful
from your brain but for sure it's got to
come a little bit from my upbringing
from my parents my coaches my
friends and just examples hmm
what do you think about um
i mean your your accomplishments put you
in the bull's-eye
of this ongoing i don't want to call it
a debate a conversation
around the role of of
of you know um male versus female
in terms of prowess in the ultra world
right like
the longer the science basically proves
that the longer the distance is
the less of a difference sex makes right
so
these 240s like these super long races
like whether you're male
male or female seems to not make
very much of a difference and it's one
of the few
sports in which the women can like crush
the dudes
i think as the distance increases
it becomes a little more equal for sure
because
then it is a lot in your head and it's
about you know persistence and problem
solving and
um some stubbornness you know all those
factor in quite a bit as you're out
there for over 24 hours
right i think like big's backyard is a
great example
of a format that i think is pretty equal
in what's possible and who might win it
every single year
where it's that four mile loop every
single hour
line up on the hour every hour and do it
again yeah
until no one will anymore right it
becomes a it becomes a
a battle of will as much as anything
else right and i want to talk about that
in a minute because i think that's
fascinating um
but being a science teacher former
science teacher
right it makes me think perhaps there
is some evolutionary advantage that
that females developed as the child
rearers
that they are they have they carry with
them
like a deeper reservoir of
psychological endurance and capacity
versus men right it seems to like it
would make sense i don't know if anybody
studied this
yeah i have no idea i think it would be
a cool thing for someone
to focus their studies on if they aren't
already yeah
yeah it's wild it's wild i remember
um like before you were born
when i was after i was i grew up as a
swimmer
um and after college i moved to new york
city and my roommate
this guy matt nance was a teammate of
mine very good swimmer
much better than me and he decided to do
the race around manhattan which is a
28-mile swim around the island of
manhattan
and at this time i had no interest in
any intern i was like go
go for it like i'm not interested um and
he ended up
getting second place and i think he i
can't remember this was like 1990.
i think he broke the course record but
he got beat by a 15 year old girl from
australia wow
this girl susie moroney who who ended up
winning that race a
bunch of times maybe three times or
something like that you know so
at a 28 mile swim like she just she just
crushed him
i should beat him by like five minutes
or something like that really yeah a
sprint finish
uh no i think she had a good lead on him
okay
yeah at that point but you know
it goes to that point of when you reach
a certain distance
um i don't want to say gender because
it's not gender it's sexual
it's what you call it sexual genetics
um really don't play the factor that
they do
in other sport pursuits
yeah i mean i think it it gets closer
for sure i would love to just i mean
200s are kind of new
so i would love to you know see how over
the years
with if there's more men more women
competing like just get more
people out there and see what happens
because i think i mean those 200s are
fun
because there's like not a ton of
information about
how they're done or you know what's the
formula to
do this as fast as possible whereas like
there's tons of hundred mile races
that i mean you can look at people's
splits you could
you know read about their very specific
training like there's all sorts of
information about that and the 200s i
think it's just a little
less known um and there's a few more
variables that make it hard to
right yeah it's the it's at the cutting
edge of where this sport is going i mean
it's crazy how much the sport is blown
up
and the fact that so many people sign up
for 100 mile races now
is like wild yeah they all sell out i
know
yeah and it's weird how the mine goes
well
okay 200. like as if it's somewhat the
same thing
yeah like it's only double like the
longest thing you can ever imagine
right and how many people are actually
signing up for 200
i mean in maybe in five or ten years it
will be like the hundreds are right
now right i think so but there's so
little it's so new
right that you're one of the pioneers
here trying to figure out how to
optimize performance at that distance
it's a
fun one to play with do you wish that
the races were like 300 miles
absolutely 400 miles like the longer the
better right keep going
i know when you were on rogan there was
some discussion about a 500 mile race
yeah that hasn't happened yet um but
like the colorado trail that i tried is
about 500 miles and so
i was kind of looking for starting to
figure out that distance with that
right so that was your first um
ftk attempt that was sort of a covet
inspired
pursuit right like all the races were
canceled so you were gonna
tackle this trail which takes you from
durango to denver
correct 500 miles yeah you got a little
hiccup though
yeah what happened well
oh man it's a beautiful trail i mean
it's this
beautiful single track that goes over
tons of mountain ranges
through the state of colorado and i had
been eyeing it for a few years but
the pandemic and all the races being
canceled for sure
suddenly made it like i mean we had a
wide open summer
to just go for it um so i ended up
making it about 300 and
i don't know five miles um and then was
put in the er
because my lungs just weren't working
like they were supposed to
yeah you had to be put on like oxygen
right
yeah yeah yeah it was weird because
it started early on like right when i
started the trail
i remember commenting to my crew at one
of the stops like
everything feels amazing but my lungs
just are
being lazy right now i thought they just
weren't turning on like the rest of it
but
i figured they just needed some more
hours you know and then they would be
they would realize what we were doing
and they would come with
right it comes around like that's that
thing in ultras where you can't really
make a
informed decision about what's going on
or how you feel based on the moment
because it changes
exactly um but it just kept getting
worse so i was like wheezing and
uh coughing up a lot of things and um it
was preventing
like any good forward motion but also
like sleep wasn't possible anymore
because every time i laid down i was
just
like wheezing like i was breathing
through a tiny straw
right and you had crew with you the
whole way
i did yeah
you know a situation where you were out
of cell range or anything like that
in real jeopardy yeah i always had a
crew um
i always had someone running with me who
had like a
satellite thing that they could
communicate so
we could have figured it out if anything
had really
gone uh to the garbage but
my crew just like made the call
at uh 305 where we had stopped for
a rest stop and uh
they had been you know watching this get
progressively worse over the course of
these days
and then finally they were like we got
to just go to this hospital nearby
and get you checked out and beforehand i
had told them like
you know what we're trying to do so if
you decide
something about like how much i should
rest or not rest or eat or not eat like
i trust you a hundred percent because i
know my brain is going to turn to
mush and so when they said that i i mean
for sure i needed a little explanation
of like
you know i've been wheezing for hundreds
of miles at this point like
i thought we were just going to take
that wheeze to denver like
it was coming all the way that's where
like maybe you don't have a coach but
you need some
third-party you know intervention here
because your
your your mental toughness will forbid
you from stopping
yeah i mean even coming into that spot i
had told them
like i just want to grab a slice of
pizza and then let's keep going
you know and they were like no please
stop and rest so i stopped to rest and
they were like hey we're going to take
you to the hospital
um and even on the drive to the hospital
in my head i was like
i'm just gonna tell this doctor what i'm
doing and he's gonna say
that's fine go back out there
as he's putting everything oxygen on
your face and you're not going anywhere
right i'm sure they were really worried
i mean there was a sense that you know
that something could be
really wrong yeah and i mean hindsight
like i'm so thankful
that the crew made that tough call
because they were as invested in it as i
was
you know they didn't want to pull the
plug and uh
but then the doctor you know kind of
painted the picture of
this could have gone really far south if
they hadn't brought you in
right do you think it's that thing where
you probably had some
really low-grade infection but you're
out there crushing it and it just
depresses your immune response right so
it allows that infection to take root in
a way that if you were just sitting at
home on the couch
you would have been fine yeah i think it
had to have
been something like that because of how
it felt at the beginning
where i you know wanted my lungs to wake
up and they weren't and it
feels like something was brewing in
there but with acute bronchitis they
don't have like a they can't pinpoint
the cause
sure yeah and in these
super long races it's those tiny little
things that
can end up burying you right yeah yeah
which is why it's
so cool i mean the longer the
race gets or the longer the you know
challenge you're taking on gets the more
puzzle pieces
there are that get involved and i think
just playing around with those
every time it makes you better at doing
the puzzles but also
like um it's just a fun game to me
yeah so there's there's events like that
this self-styled like i'm gonna tackle
this trail and do it faster than anybody
there's the structured races like the
moab 240 or utmb
which is kind of like the super bowl of
trail races um and then there are these
last man standing races
right the the backyard ultra that you
referenced earlier
which i think is such a cool format yes
um do you
like is there is there one of those
formats that
you enjoy best like i feel like the the
the the backyard ultra format the last
man standing kind of thing is
perfectly suited for you yeah i love
those i love all the events though
um they just change in what i love about
them like
a 240 or 100 mile race i love because
it's usually a really cool
course you know you're getting to
explore with your feet
and then ones like these loop courses
it's
more like exploring in your brain of
how to go a little bit deeper right so
for just so you know like there there's
a percentage of the audience that
is probably a super fan of yours and
knows everything that you've done but
there's also a large percentage of them
for
whom perhaps this is their first
introduction to you so let's talk about
what this backyard ultra situation is
you do this
four mile loop right and basically you
they're on the hour essentially yep
they're on the hour so you run four
miles and
however long it takes and then you just
have to start the next loop
at the top of the hour and then you just
keep going until no one's left
so the re you don't know how long the
race is going to be exactly right
and so you just did this uh this this
past year and ended up running 283
miles that's correct it's like 67 loops
is that right uh yeah 67. you're the ma
you're the science person right a lot of
loops
67 or something until it was just you
and harvey lewis
yeah right yeah who's an amazing human
um and it was just the two of us from
um 200 miles on
so the way the race works is everyone
starts
all at once and then every loop you're
starting again all together so you're
never you can't like
get ahead by a certain amount of time or
right bank time anywhere it's
one hour and that's it every lap yeah
um and you can either
quit and refuse to start another lap or
you can miss the
hour cut off and that's how the field
just starts getting smaller and smaller
so it ended up with harvey and i at
about 204 miles or so
and we're i mean the cool part about
this format is you
need each other right because once it's
once you're the last person standing the
race is over
you can't keep going yeah you don't get
to keep doing those four mile laps even
if you feel fine
so harvey and i were like full-on
let's work as a team we want to get you
know over 300 miles
how can we help each other and we talk
on the loops like
what do you need what do i need how do
we
keep this train rolling um but then part
of it is also
you've gone so far that you need to like
really just focus on like not imploding
yourself
right and so um there were quite a few
laps where we were both just like
totally focused inward on on keeping it
moving
yeah but that is beautiful and very
unique in that your
your main competitor must become your
ally
if you really want to push the envelope
and see what's possible for each of you
i think it's so cool and that to be
going that far you both need
so many things to have gone right for
you like
that's a far ways to run with your feet
so there's all these like hurdles along
the way that you have to navigate and
um to have two people have days like
that is
is really special right but i think i
mean
the whole field is like a team everyone
wants
everyone to keep going the more numbers
you have getting into those higher
distances the more likely
everyone is to keep going farther yeah
because if you're surrounded by 10
people
it feels less crazy than if you're
surrounded by right
one person right right right yeah it
goes back to that
mental game it's the same notion that
when
you know prior to banister breaking the
four minute mile mark people thought it
was impossible
he breaks it then suddenly you know all
kinds of people are breaking it like
it's so strange that that's the way the
human
mind operates yeah but it is true
it's very true yeah but did you feel
like you
like you could have kept going if if
there was somebody like harvey
taps out yeah i
i mean yes i was set on continuing on
and in the moment i felt like i could do
more but
you never know like that
the race is as crazy as it is because
one bad hour
can take you out right and then suddenly
you're done
one bad footstep yeah you roll your
ankle or something like that happens
yeah so yeah i was when he dropped i
had gotten into this really good zone i
was like
kind of robotic through the loop and i
knew my spots where i ran and i knew my
spots where i walked and it was like
just put it on autopilot and um yeah
i was kind of having fun like being a
robot
and where does your mind go like what's
happening are you
daydreaming are you focused on what
you're doing are you listening to music
an audiobook like what what is that
about so when he
stopped it was in the night and um in
the night sections we switched to a road
out and back and there's music allowed
in the night so i think i was
blasting some music and then i was i
think i was just like
really embracing the robot mentality of
like
don't think about anything just do
and like stay right where your feet are
because that one
any ultra really but that format in
particular if you project
too far ahead like how much farther are
we going to be going
are you kidding we have to run until
sunrise or like
or you start thinking about how the
other person is looking
and like they'll never quit you know
yeah um
then it can get into your head and
spiral pretty quickly yeah no
that's helpful no you just have to be
where your feet are
right yeah but that's a discipline
yeah it's hard um but i'll even like
talk outside
uh i'll talk out loud to myself like no
stay right here if i start thinking
ahead too far
yeah what else do you tell yourself
[Laughter]
mostly it's like stay here and then this
is fine
and i'll just say that over and over
this is fine
this is fine we're good no matter what
uh-huh
and when you come in at the conclusion
of a
of a loop obviously you're eating you're
trying to rest like what does that
routine look like and what is the sleep
piece
yeah i think this is the one where
i i mean just doing the race format
you learn so much from it and seeing you
know what's helpful
what does five minutes feel like what
does eight minutes feel like
of sleep learning all of that or just
time like
i mean we rarely look and see what five
minutes
feels like when we're just like in
normal life but when you're
in this format five minutes is really
important
and you need to use it fully right
like everything should have a purpose
and so i think i was averaging
daytime loops at like maybe 48
minutes or 50 minutes and then nighttime
loops because it's that road
out and back it's a little easier and so
i was probably coming in at more like 45
um so you're getting anywhere between 10
or 15 minutes
yeah at night i was uh
we had a really good routine of just i
would come in the
little tent i had a cot set up and i
would shovel
some bites of food and then i would lay
down and i'd have like
10 minutes until the two minute whistle
blew
and then i would get up maybe drink some
things and then get back
out there and even if i wasn't falling
asleep i would just lay
there pretending like i was sleeping
yeah yeah and uh
just convincing myself that that pays
off also
were you able to fall asleep though a
bunch of times yeah
so there's the famous story of in the
moab 240 you you you got one minute of
sleep for the whole thing but you felt
like you
slept for hours or something right fully
recharged after one
really one minute it was it was that's
so crazy
so crazy i thought my pacer had tricked
me i thought he let me sleep for
45 minutes there it was 60 seconds
you're mad at him
yeah why'd you let me oversleep
yeah now you're getting you could get
like 10 minutes of sleep
yeah i've never been able to replicate
that one minute
nap though like i did another 200 mile
race
uh the tahoe 200 and i was trying i was
hoping for that match
i know how to do this yeah i totally
thought i had figured out the sleep
thing and then
i couldn't get it to work again so
i mean that keeps me coming back to
these as well as like you think you
learn
something you think you have a puzzle
piece figured out and then you gotta
throw it back in and start again
do you think that that the sleep
deprivation
part of the whole thing is something
that some people are better at than
others or do you think is this hard for
everyone
like i feel like maybe you're you're
well suited to manage that maybe better
than other people
like is that part of something you would
consider to be an advantage
maybe i'm not sure though i think yeah
you don't think about it
that's it that's my answer for
everything yeah well listen
it's working for you don't think about
it we did it we figured it out
there's nothing you could do about it
either you're good at it or you're not
right
yeah but i've so i'm still learning and
i'm like
i love that i can use myself as this
guinea pig and just test
things and see um and like johann steen
is another
runner who has done backyard races
amongst many other things and watching
him the first
year at the uh backyard race that i went
to
he would come through a loop sit down
and immediately
be sleeping every single lap that year
so he's like nailed it and i would like
to
figure it out so i could nail it like
that
[Music]
we'll be back in a sec but first if you
dig this podcast and i hope you dig this
podcast then i think you'll really enjoy
my latest book
voicing change featuring excerpts from
poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of
my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing
this thing this podcast
it's a gorgeous artful compendium of the
show
and copious wisdom shared therein all
wrapped in
a hardcover coffee table form that
provides a great taste of what we do
here
at the rrp and serves as a beautiful
keepsake or gift for the ardent fan the
book is only
and exclusively available on our website
signed copies are available
and we are shipping globally direct to
any coffee table on planet earth so to
learn more
and snag your copy today visit
richroll.com
vc that's richroll.com
vc all right let's get back into it
so as a tinkerer or somebody who is
experimenting
but is also self-coached like what is
something that you've learned
over maybe even the last two or two and
a half years
that you're doing now that you weren't
doing in 2018
or 2019 like what what where are the
where are the kind of evolutionary arcs
in
in your training or your kind of
strategy with these races
that's tricky i think getting on trails
more
and mm-hmm yeah playing on mountains
more pledged more play yeah um
and then i think just learning from all
the problems that come up like
you do these long races inevitably
there's problems that come up
and then you've experienced those
problems so then you have this filing
cabinet
in your brain where you can say like
here's all the things that i know of
already that
can go wrong and that can help you
better prepare for the next one
where maybe those things happen again
but also maybe something brand new
but also having having collecting all
those experiences you know
when things get tough like i've been
here before yeah and this is what i did
or i got through it so i know i can get
through it again
yeah for sure i'll think that if i'm you
know like puking in the bushes i can
open up a whole folder in this filing
cabinet of
times i've been throwing up during a
race you know and like
then the options that i have of what
worked before or what i at least tried
before
right i feel like you need to get into a
lab
and have some test run you know like
like they've done tests on killian they
know he has a crazy
you know threshold um alex honold
has had his brain yeah analyzed and they
realize he
his brain is a little bit different when
it comes to his fear response like i
feel like we need to get
dr andrew huberman my uh neuroscience
buddy
to test your head and see what's going
on or like
do you like have you had all those
markers uh
evaluated so you know where you are you
haven't even done that right
like i feel like let's get you in the
lab let's figure out what's going on
what if they only find air but that
would be instructive too
right now we know you know like yeah
like either
you have some you know genetic
disposition
that that differentiates you and even if
you don't
that's super interesting also you know
because then it does
then it does i think in my mind that
tells me
oh this person has developed um
you know a mental toughness that you
can't
calibrate with any scientific rigor you
know that and that's interesting to
explore in and of itself
yeah i would be curious what
they would be like testing for or
looking for
well they could test your like i mean
you you you
you're not wearing a watch right i don't
know measure yeah i know right i don't
know
i don't know maybe some scientist knows
how to do that it's not crazy but
you know they could test your aerobic
threshold and your your resting heart
rate and your heart rate variability
and like all of that kind of stuff that
you ignore yeah
you wear a watch though when you're
running don't you i do wear a heart rate
monitor
nope um i just have the one that's built
into the
watch but i don't really use heart rate
mm-hmm
just go is that surprising no it's not
surprising at all like
i kind of i kind of love it you know i
think i have a good gauge of effort
i'm sure you know yeah it's like you're
so you're so connected
to yourself that you you don't need that
because you already know intuitively
where you're at
right and that comes with experience
you've been doing this for a long time
pretty long yeah i mean when did you you
started running cross-country in
junior high high school yeah cross
country
um starting in middle school and then
cross country skiing
through high school yeah and you were a
state champion in cross-country skiing
yeah aren't you yeah why are you like
laughing
why is that so funny it's not i'm just
awkward
you're not awkward relax we're just
having fun here it's all good
it's all good um it seems like your
parents are really
um supportive and cool yeah they're the
best
they're amazing i was watching that the
the video that solomon made
around the western states with your
parents there they were so cute
yeah being interviewed they were they
were so fired up to
get to see this race where it's like
kind of
there's so many crowds and so much
excitement around it so
i was really lucky they could come out
for it um
ever since i started doing these ultras
they've been
full on supportive and like the first
100-mile race that i ended up finishing
so my second one i had signed up for
it was just my dad and brother and uh
kevin
as my crew none of us knew what we were
doing and we're like
you know up in the woods of minnesota at
the superior 100
like figuring out what these aid
stations are
and what the trail looks like and how to
even like go about getting to a finish
line yeah i think
there's this misconception that you
like won your first race and it's just
been podiums ever since but you started
in what like 2012
running ultras and it was a couple years
of you growing and learning before you
hit your stride and started winning
for sure yeah it took a lot of races
to start to put the pieces together
uh-huh
did you know with that first one then
though that like oh this is gonna be my
thing
no i think um so i just
stumbled upon the ultra running world i
had no idea they existed
and uh there was a 50k at a local park
so i signed up for that
and was intrigued by it but i wasn't
like hooked on the sport right away
and then i did a 50-mile race a little
bit later that year and that
got me hooked all the way and then i
just wanted to know
what else was out there and what could i
try what was the decision to sign up for
the first race though why were you
interested to begin with
um so i did a road marathon and
surprised myself by finishing it like i
didn't think i'd actually
get to the finish line of 26.2 miles i
thought
my legs would shatter i thought i would
die on the side of this road
and when i finished it it kind of like
flipped a switch for me of just
wondering if that sounded too hard but i
did it
what else is there that sounds too hard
that i could try so i tried like a tough
mudder then
and then uh stumbled upon like these
races that were just a smidge longer
than a road marathon a 50k what
five miles more i was like i gotta try
and see
if the extra five miles kills me mm-hmm
and then i did it well if that didn't
kill me
exactly yeah so then it was a real quick
progression
i did the 50 mile race got hooked and
didn't die
and then uh instantly i wanted to try
100 miles
it really fits your your disposition
though because
as somebody who is all about intuitive
feel
to be a marathon runner is really kind
of a data driven thing like oh here are
the workouts you need to do
and here's how you have to hit your
splits but trail running is all about
the terrain dictating everything
so all of that goes out the window and
it's just about like
being present in the experience and
tackling things as
as they're thrown at you yeah it's not
about anyone else other than you
and you yeah i think in that 50k i was
so surprised
that everyone was chatting out on this
trail you know winding through the woods
no one's watches were beeping splits and
then at aid stations we got to just
fill our pockets with jelly beans i was
like i'm in
we're going to talk about your garbage
patch kids
diet in a minute i feel like we have a
lot in common there
yeah oh my goodness
you're young there's more to learn
it is interesting as somebody who's
trying to to achieve
peak performance in all these areas that
that
your approach is to not focus on all
these things
where people are trying to get that
incremental advantage whether it's
through
some scientific approach to training or
or a dietary approach like you're just
like no
not doing that i eat whatever nachos
cheeseburgers french fries
so good candy right has that evolved at
all
no no no and i realized like that
is definitely an area where maybe if i
did something differently um maybe it
would help but
then like weighing that against how much
joy i get out of just living life
like this yeah i just i love nachos
too much i don't blame you i'm not i'm
i'm like i got nothing but love
okay that you know i think
the enjoyment piece is really important
because
if you're not enjoying yourself then
you're putting a shelf life on your
career
and if it becomes too rigorous or
restricted whether it's through training
or diet or any other
you know like sleeping in an altitude
town like all these you know like you
don't even use normatec boots right
no not changed no he couldn't remember
what they were called but
like that's something that is like de
rigueur with endurance athletes and you
were like i don't even know what that is
like that's nuts but the good thing is
if you ever get interested in those
things then there's a whole world of
opportunity and possibility ahead of you
yeah to explore all that stuff
i'll just keep them in my back pocket
right yeah pull it out
when you need it but so far so good
right um
let's talk about the barkley marathons
yeah let's
i'm fascinated by this
race and the people involved and what
this is all about so
explain what it is for people who've
never heard of it
so it's a race in the mountains of
tennessee
um outside of a prison and i believe the
history
came about because a prisoner escaped
this prison
and when he was found 60 hours later he
had only made it
like five miles or something from the
prison and
so laz uh lazarus lake is the race
director and
i guess him and his buddies were just
jawbone in about how
they would make it farther and they
should then make this race
out there so it's it's not
marked like a normal ultra marathon is
and it's not
on actual trails it's just bushwhacking
through
these mountains and uh you have to
complete five 20-ish mile
loops in order to be a finisher of the
barkley marathons you say
20-ish because they say it's 20 but it's
not 20. it's not
20. um but maybe
25 or 26 mile loops not positive
and the way you prove that you made it
around the loop correctly
is he's hidden books out in the woods
and you have to
get to the book and then you rip out
your bib number
to prove you were at that book and then
turn them in when you finish your loop
right and it's uncrewed there's no aid
stations
the only time you can get more things is
when you're
back at the camp between loops and then
there's a few
stops uh out on the course where he's
put some jugs of water
uh-huh and over is it five loops total
five completed and there's something
like sixty thousand feet of
elevation gain right yeah easily i bet
uh-huh
i don't know so you're out there it's
not marked you don't really know where
you're going i mean people are getting
lost all the time right yeah
yeah you're the weather's terrible the
weather is
horrendous um and you're navigating just
with a compass
and the day before the race he puts out
his map that you copy on to your own map
of like the line you're supposed to take
it's not a orienteering race it's not
like
you can just go any direction through
these woods to get to the books you're
supposed to follow his line
and isn't it a thing where he doesn't
tell you when it's going to start yeah
yeah he gives you a one-hour warning so
it can be
anywhere in this like i don't know
12-hour window of time or something
20-hour window of time and he'll give
you the one-hour warning
and this year um i was lucky enough to
get to try the race and he
uh gave that warning at like 2 a.m
or something right 3 a.m start yeah he
lights the cigarette
which is the thing he does i mean he's a
character of this guy he's like
what is the story with this dude
controversial too yeah
he's a character but he's created all
these events where
like he just wants to help people see
what's possible for them so
like barkley is that you know people
sign up for it
knowing they're not gonna finish
probably
i think in total there's been 15
finishers
ever of the barkley and then he's
created a big's backyard where it's like
you know run till you can't basically so
15 people
total finish i thought it was a little a
few more than that i don't know
but no woman has done the whole has
completed the whole thing
is that correct right um
and when you did it you did you
completed the first loop
within the time limit and then on the
second loop
uh came in like like 12 minutes yeah too
late
yep we were 12 minutes over the cutoff
so we weren't allowed to then leave on
our third loop uh-huh
so there's did anybody finish no uh
two people made it the fun run which is
three loops
so they uh i think it's like 40 hours
you have to get three loops done in
in order to count for a fun run right
but it doesn't actually count as
right yeah so this is like the only race
where
almost where basically nobody finishes
like every single year
yeah how long has it been going on uh
a long time yeah me i'm not sure
we can look that up i know are you gonna
go back to that
you gotta crack that i'm really
intrigued by it like just getting my
feet wet and getting to
actually see what it's all about was
really cool um
i mean it's just as hard as as everyone
says like it's just straight up and down
these mountain sides um and then finding
the books is like this
silly game where they're like hidden in
the most obscure places
like it's like in a hole under a rock
on this log you know like it's hard to
find them
i can't imagine like being that tired
and it's like dark out too
right yeah so you have this map and
you're like the book's supposed to be
here and you can't find it
yeah luckily i was with veterans and so
they had a better gauge on like the lay
of the land and
um just having been there before like
there's some spots that he
repeats the book being hidden there so
they knew
like oh we lift up this one rock and you
know then it's
wherever right um but like the whole
first
half of the first loop this year was in
the dark
and then it was in the fog and so
everyone going to the race had told me
pay attention on that first loop you
know figure out your landmarks
so that when you do it again on the
second loop you start to piece it
together and you can like
see the land in your head and you know
where you're going kind of
and that whole first half of the first
loop i'm like
i couldn't see like 10 feet out i'm like
guys i'm really
trying to see the land oh my god
so all right a couple questions first of
all the map that you have
is that on a like a an iphone with a gps
or is that a piece of paper
no technology so right so you can't see
the your dot
thing and to make sure that you're on
course yeah no
phones no gps watches he issues you
it is an orienteering race then you said
it's not but it kind of is
kind of except in orienteering can't
they go however to get to the point oh i
don't know
because this is like a very specific
path to get to the book that you're
supposed to follow
so maybe it's a little bit orienteering
but
not like a free-for-all like did you
change it up like could you go
at other parts of the year and train on
the course so you get familiar with all
the rock formations and everything
you can't train off trail in the park
and so like the park makes a special
exception for this race every year to
happen
off trail but otherwise during the year
you have to stay on
just their normal park trails right
right but this year the watch he gave us
was a
like a pocket watch like clicks open
with the lid you know
and you know it was
so useless right and isn't it that um
like the entry fee is like a dollar
sixty or something and then there's
always some random
thing also like a license plate yep
license plate
uh if you're new to the race you have to
bring a license plate that year
and then if you've done the race before
there's like a different
thing you bring him i think he's done
like socks and
cigarettes and whatever else oh my god
yeah it's pretty cool though i mean it
was just like
it was silly the weather was so bad that
a few times
i was with a small group we're just
going up and down these hillsides and
everyone's just slipping everywhere
there's mud down the whole hillside
and so like zooming out and watching it
i'm like this is like a comedy
movie like people are just slipping and
falling and like tumbling and then
back on their feet and running like it
was the most normal thing to be doing
right right right well i'm wondering
whether
there's something so beautiful and pure
about that but
also balancing that against you know
risk and liability as this sport is
continuing to grow like it's very much
in its
you know juvenile years in terms of
um you know what we're what we're
learning about what's
physically and mentally possible but
also in terms of onboarding all of these
enthusiastic runners who are looking to
push their limits
and we just saw what happened in china
recently
where 21 people died and when you know
it's fun to talk oh we're sliding around
in mud but like there's
real life you know ramifications of this
where people can get seriously hurt we
saw that
and it's going to be interesting to see
how that impacts race directors and
races going forward in the united states
like it's a cautionary tale like this is
very real and
people are pushing themselves to places
that not everybody's ready to go
yeah you know and they can be inspired
by you but if they're not
somebody who's been doing this for a
long time um people can get into
very real trouble pretty for sure yeah
and like just because it's this
marked course doesn't give you this
bubble of safety
around it like it's still mountains and
they're still yeah and you're in these
remote places
there's no hospitals nearby and most of
these races
remain very grassroots you know there's
just a couple people there
there's not a lot of infrastructure and
that's what makes it great and cool and
fun
and and cultivates this amazing
community and
rapport that you have with everybody but
on some on some level there is a there
is a you know sort of this is that that
event
you know makes me think like well maybe
it's time to
mature a little bit yeah
or yeah i don't know if like the
application process needs more
you know information from each runner
stronger stronger waivers
yeah like but also like can you make
smart choices out there like what's your
wilderness wilderness training
or um experience and that kind of thing
i don't know i don't know what the
solution is but
it's it's scary how real it became
when something like that race happens
and at the same time
there's there's money coming into the
sport we just saw iron man
partnering with utmb which is another
controversial thing like how do you feel
about that
i i'm not sure i don't know
i guess we don't know yet right yeah
you'll probably learn more
when you go to the race this year yeah
we'll all have what what aspects of the
race are going to be impacted by it
relatively or negatively yeah
we'll see yeah you're going to be very
politic here
i mean it's hard it's hard to know right
now i think the fear
you know the fear is that it will
corrupt the integrity of it um on the
positive side there's an infusion of
money
that could make the sport better and you
know create
opportunities for for more runners
um but i think protecting you know the
integrity and the legacy
and what makes ultra running and that
community special
is important and so i think people are
afraid that that partnership could
threaten that
yeah yeah and i mean i'm not even trying
to
stay neutral i feel like i've just read
a lot of things where it's like
guessing what might happen right all
these hot takes but we don't know yet
yeah
we don't know we'll see soon enough
right yeah
um what is your uh
of the two races that you're preparing
for right now uh
let's talk about the differences between
something like hard rock and utmb
because they're they're very different
yeah the courses will be
uh kind of similar i mean they're both
mountain terrain
lots of climbing but
just the races in general are
all the way different hard rock has like
150 people in the race
utmb has thousands and thousands
um it's crazy the crowds yeah i show up
for that
yeah i mean i've only been over there
once but it was insane i've
never experienced anything like that but
i'm excited to have
both of them um i think it's so cool
when you
roll into an aid station that's you know
just a folding table out in the middle
of nowhere yeah with some volunteers
that camped there the night before
to get there i think that's just as
special as like rolling through a
you know hyped up town with you know
crazy tense and nascar style crewing
so it'll be fun to have these races that
are both
you know beautiful mountain 100-mile
races but then
different in so many other ways and what
does the training look like in between
the two are you just trying to like
recover as much as possible so you can
be
fresh yeah i think that'll be really
play it by ear and see
what my body needs and how my brain is
feeling
maybe some weeks of training squeezed in
there but maybe it'll just be like
recovering and then trying to show up as
fresh as possible
yeah at utmb well i can still just wake
up in the morning and figure it out
right
yeah after coffee
um it's cool i can't wait to see what
you're
what you're gonna do do you feel um
like you shoulder a little bit more
pressure
and a sense of expectations now because
of your accomplishments does it change
how you
approach these races for me it doesn't
no i mean i expect from myself to
give it everything i have and so what
someone else is expecting from me
is like not part of the equation
yeah that's pretty healthy i'll do my
very best
no matter what that's a that's a healthy
mental approach
i mean we're we're i don't know if you
saw this this past weekend with naomi
osaka like
refusing to do press yeah i just saw
that mental health
which made the internet explode yeah but
i thought it was really cool that she's
like
listen you know i'm not a product and i
need to protect myself and
why should i expose myself to all of
these you know
reporters who say negative things and
that affects my ability to perform
and i think it's created a really
interesting conversation about
the um responsibility of the media and
and um the empowerment of the athlete to
like say no to this stuff like just
because you're
competing at this level doesn't mean
that you owe
anybody anything yeah super interesting
she dropped out of the tournament now i
think yeah i think so yeah
yeah how old is she do you know
i don't know i should know she's young
though pretty young yeah yeah yeah
but that was a bold that was a
courageous thing to do i think yeah
you know and there were a lot of the the
the people on the other side saying this
is your job
right this goes with the territory you
should know this
and on some level yes you make yourself
available to the press but doesn't that
need to be
reasonable and within certain parameters
and can't we respect the
sovereignty of the athlete when they say
enough is enough yeah probably all the
social media
changes the dynamics of sports
what is your approach to social media
like do you feel like you need to be
sharing stuff and you've got sponsors
and
people that you know want you to be kind
of out there in that way
yeah i mean i'm sort of i feel sort of
new to it
still um but i just it's a cool way to
connect
with people is how i view it and so like
i am having fun sharing my story
using it because maybe it can connect
with someone who
maybe it helps them try something hard
you know
i don't know and i i mean my sponsors
are fantastic so
um i don't have pressure from them to
like
do a certain thing or yeah
solomon is your main sponsor that's
correct yeah you know i just
joined the solomon team i'm so excited
yeah now we gotta i think we're gonna
announce it tomorrow
i'm super excited about it um no i
it's hilarious like oh joining the
solomon family i'm like
with people like courtney like i don't
like i'm way in the back like
i can't even believe that i'm here but
i'm really excited about it and
i love all the people that i've met and
gotten to spend a little bit of time
with and
everything is just so dialed in and
super
pro from the gear to just the integrity
and it's been
really it's like a dream come true for
me oh that's so cool so aaron was
suppose aaron
and juris were supposed to come out and
do the iron cowboy thing with me the
other day but their
their young end wasn't feeling well so i
couldn't do it but i was hoping to see
them
on saturday they're so great yeah i'm so
pumped you're on the team
i know i should i should figure out some
kind of i feel like i have
i really have to live up
um i got to find some kind of challenge
for myself or whatever to
legitimize the relationship i'm really
proud i'm really proud would you want to
do a backyard race
maybe i have to put in quite a bit of
work between now and maybe in a year
i have to get ready i got to heal my
back if you had to choose between a
backyard or a 200
i think i can wrap my head around a
backyard yeah yeah
that's what's cool about it is that it
can be as as hard as your body is able
to go right and those little breaks
become super significant yeah you know
yeah and mentally it's not as
intimidating
yeah it is a cool format i mean
the first year i was there i think uh
there was a person who was like
i'm just gonna try to run my first
marathon ever today
and they wanted to stay in to get their
miles and then they were gonna feel
satisfied and they ended up doing i
think
100k like 62 miles because
four miles at a time they just kept
thinking like oh i can do one more
yeah i can do one more yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think the the goggins challenge
where he did the
four four by four by 48 was a similar
thing
because it feels bite-sized and you
don't realize that it's actually hard
when you think about it until you're
actually doing it and you're in the
middle of the night
right and it encourages people to try
something that maybe
they would have been too intimidated to
do if it was signing up for like a
really long race yeah
absolutely yeah i want to i want to
think of
something like like create my own thing
though too
like i think there's something cool
about that and and you know if there was
a
uh silver lining to the to the
pandemic with respect to ultras it was
the
like backyard the backyard challenge
thing
that was was mike wardian the one who
created that he's the one who went the
furthest
to do the virtual backyard yeah the
virtual thing yeah
yeah it was dave proctor and his team in
canada
who like put together the event yeah
yeah those things are cool yeah to be
able to create community when we
couldn't be together
yeah oh it was so fun i know it felt
like we were
all hanging out together even though i
was just staring at this little screen
right i know well it must be nice to
feel like you can
start traveling now and the world is
opening up a little bit
yeah it feels awesome yeah like seeing
people
doing things i i think though like
i i kind of liked last year and um
like finding appreciation in these
trails that were right out my door all
the time
that i had you know gotten to i took
taking them for granted
basically and then being stuck at home
all last spring and into the summer it
was like
oh there's a lot of cool link-ups you
can actually make if
you're just looking for it right and
encourage you to explore a little bit
more yeah
and i saw way more families out on the
trails and
just getting outside more so i think it
could have some cool
things come from it even though it was
definitely not great
amelia boone lives in golden also
doesn't she do you ever go running with
her
no i i saw her during a virtual
run i was doing um and we crossed paths
on the trails but
otherwise we haven't run together really
didn't you but one of the
because the the the backyard ultra you
do it in
teams right that like the the us has
their team and there was like wasn't
amelia
part of one of you yes that was in
person
at uh in tennessee in the fall yeah we
were able to share a ton of miles there
um but never in golden uh-huh that's so
that's funny yeah i feel like i had this
idea like oh you guys are like hanging
out and running and having coffee
and doing stuff like that all the time
no
no not recently yeah we should what is
the
the ultra running community
of the future that you would like to see
like where is all this heading and like
you know explain to somebody who's
listening or watching
who's unfamiliar with this world like
what's great about it
and why maybe they should think of
stepping into it oh
man so many reasons just exploring
with your feet like the places you end
up with
just your body carrying you there is
pretty cool
and it feels special to be in the middle
of nowhere and to have gotten yourself
there
on purpose i think it's the most
welcoming community my
the first 50 mile race i did one of the
things was
that hooked me was how awesome the
people
around me were and i mean we were in
hail and sleet and
just awful weather and people were
wearing garbage bags
as their raincoats because it kept them
a little bit warmer
and all signs pointed to like we should
be hating life right now
but people were just making the best of
it they were hooping and hollering you
know splashing through puddles
finding like all the joy they could in
this
miserable situation and uh
they're also the most helpful because in
that same race i
uh face planted in a mud puddle and a
person 15 yards ahead
ran back offered their hand and pulled
me out of this
puddle to keep running together like
where does that happen
yeah you went out of your way to help me
it's not just that i was conveniently
in your way like they turned around and
came back for me
that is something really unique about
the community i think
and i find that in every race i mean
everyone's
ready to help if you're on the side of
the trail having trouble like
everyone who goes by is going to ask
what can i do
how can i help you to get back on track
and you might even hallucinate
and you could go blind yeah
also perks can we talk about the
hallucinations
have you ever vaccinated no uh yeah
it's fun you make some good friends yeah
i like your it's for me i mean you hear
lots of stories of ultra
runners having hallucinations um but
what i love about your hallucinations is
your relationship to them like they're
like your friends or something like
you're like oh this is awesome there's
mickey mouse over there
doing whatever like what is going on
mickey mouse was
throwing out t-shirts to the crowd and
he did not throw me one
do you know they're not real when
they're happening so there's a
detachment or are you
are you thinking this is really real and
it's still cool
for the most part now i can tell they're
not real there are
some instances where i have to like take
you know
double or triple takes at something
because i can't believe you know i'm
seeing these people dancing right there
and like what are they doing um but
usually i can recognize
it's not real and it means that i'm
doing something really cool because
these friends don't just come out
anytime
right it's special yeah here they come
yeah do you know it's always gonna
happen at hour or whatever
it's not a certain hour but it's uh
definitely
over 24 hours of effort and then
um like night time for sure brings out
more friends
so like utmb starts in the evening
and so the night is when you're a little
bit fresher and so i
i made no friends at utmb because
you're like where are my friends yeah
even though that course would be hard
enough and take long enough where i
maybe i would have made them if the
night had been
at the end section uh-huh uh
i think you're a very healthy person i'm
no shrink
but you know i think the the the sort of
good-natured aspect of your
hallucinations
speak to somebody who's who's you know a
very grounded individual like if it was
a lot of demons coming out at night and
people trying to kill you and stuff
like i know my friend i feel like you
should write them all down and then you
could
give them give that journal to you know
a psychiatrist and say tell me who i am
yeah i don't know i don't know if i want
them to analyze it but
i had to my friend maggie who does big's
backyard and all sorts of adventures
she has really scary ones like she sees
like heads on spears and
clowns and stuff right like maggie you
gotta watch
happy movies the day before like she's
watching
it the night before a race yeah hannibal
yeah
like what do you think you're going to
see that's funny
what about the blindness though explain
that story
for people that don't know it yeah i
don't recommend it
um but what happened was it was a
hundred mile race
and about 12 miles from the finish my
vision was just getting really foggy on
the edges
i thought it was my contact lenses i
thought it was my headlamp
dying like i couldn't figure out what
was going on but i for sure
noticed i was seeing less and less and
by 10 miles out from the finish line it
just had closed in
all the way where it was pure white in
my field of vision
like i waved my hand in front of my face
and i couldn't see my hand
uh but there were 10 miles left and so
it was like
problem solving figuring out what
solutions i had
as options to keep moving forward
i didn't ever feel like it was permanent
because it had crept in like it did and
it didn't come from like
falling and hitting my head it had just
like slowly happened over time
so i determined it was safe and then if
i just stared
down at my toes i could see this tiny
arc
of the trail in front of them to keep
moving
so you could see to you know gauge your
foot
placement yes i could see that i was on
the trail still
and i knew that section of trail i knew
there weren't like spurs off of it where
i would end up
lost you know or i knew it didn't cliff
out anywhere
so i was like if i can just stay on this
single track
it'll be okay right you're not gonna
fall off a cliff yeah yeah
god i mean some areas if that happened i
would sit like
if it's an area where it does clip out
or if i'm unfamiliar with what it does
i would probably have to like make a
different choice yeah
um because i'm not trying to go off a
cliff anywhere
i hope not yeah but then i made it to an
aid station
with about six miles left and uh
the volunteers were very kind and sent
one of
their aid station workers to run next to
me
and she narrated the trail to me then
and so she was like
oh my god big rocks on your left the
trail is turning slightly to the right
and it just made it so much easier
because
i could like sort of then predict with
my body where i was going next
when i was by myself it was i was
falling everywhere because
if you can't see in front of your feet i
mean i was landing on every
rock and route and just tripping on
everything
i don't even know where to begin with
this so yeah i don't know if you should
maybe we just leave that you're like all
right moving on next
next next question i mean
come on first of all you're wearing
contacts for like
days on end right probably not a smart
idea yeah you probably stopped doing
that after that right
no because i can't see without them but
you can get
like i'm blind as a bat you just get
glasses
oh i could do that yeah right i've heard
lasik makes it
happen more often it's corneal edema
that's what's happening right so
essentially your body's
so you know under so much stress that
you're having this immune response
creating
inflammation in your eyes that that is
crowding out your ability to see like
it's basically pressure on the optic
nerve yeah
and they i mean best diagnosis or reason
they said is probably
that and it was dusty and
smoky air and like rubbing my eyes maybe
just aggravated allergic response yeah
um
but the the the frame of mind
when that happens to not freak out
and say i gotta stop like i can't see
you know and you're like oh it's good
we'll just keep going
like i think it's gonna be okay you know
it was so great i had a guide like
that's
not normal right
you recognize that um
yes and i like i don't recommend people
just
do this like maybe make the choice for
you if it ever happens to your eyes
like figure out how you feel about all
the factors
you know but but when it happened you
didn't know what corneal edema was like
now if it happens again you're like this
has happened yeah before or i read
something about it but when it was
occurring in real time
most people would have just freaked out
yeah i think um
in general how i try to stay is just
without emotions
in situations like that so like what are
the facts
of this situation and then what can i
actually control about it how long
before
your eyesight returned it was probably
like five or six hours after the finish
hmm that's a long time to just be
sitting there
like at hour four like is yeah it's just
gonna
it's gonna work out i was very happy
when it came back i went to the hospital
so
i mean they checked me out they they
weren't worried about the eyes
oh okay that's helpful yeah so what do
you do is there anything you do now to
help prevent that like drops or anything
like that yeah i do
eye drops um pretty much through every
ultra
now i'll have them in my pack or i'll
use them at aid stations
and then protective eyewear so just
trying to keep out as much dust as but
still with the contacts
yeah interesting yeah i don't know
i don't maybe i could try glasses have
you never worn glasses
not really oh i've never really worn
contacts yeah
maybe we could we can switch just do a
small start wearing contacts and you
i'll give you my glasses yeah and see
how that works out
maybe i'll get like really good at
ultras and then you'll your back will
start hurting you
[Laughter]
thank you sounds like a good trade
we can wrap this up in a few minutes but
i one thing
we're starting to lose the thread
one thing i'm interested in is
as somebody who's out there pushing the
envelope in your sport
um showing the rest of us
what's possible and breaking all these
boundaries and barriers how does that
affect your mental disposition and how
you approach
other facets of your life like how does
it spill over
and how you think about possibilities
and potential
in areas that are outside of running
i think it's possible in every area
outside of running
i'm not like seeking it in any other
area right now but i think
what it's shown me is that like
people are selling themselves short and
setting their bars too low
of what they could actually do if they
went all in
on something you know whatever they're
psyched about
to just see what happens if they invest
a little more
time and energy into it and what about
for yourself
for myself so you deflected a little bit
there what because i was asking you
about you
too i never do that yeah i know
uh like am i pursuing
am i well right now you're all in on
running right this is 100
110 all your focus and all your time
um but there are other interests i'm
sure that you have and
you're married and you have a
relationship and i'm sure there's other
goals that maybe you're thinking about
for your life after running or in
conjunction with your running
talk a little bit about that and how you
kind of
see your life unfolding i don't
know how i see it unfolding because
you're just you're right where your feet
are yeah
when i wake up in the morning and decide
yeah i
am having like i love this chapter that
it's in right now and so
just enjoying that fully and knowing
like
chapters don't go on forever so this
ride you know will end
at some point and what comes next i'm
not sure
but i hope whatever you know page it
flips to
next i can be just as excited about
finding out what's possible but you
don't have a sense of what that might
look like i don't know
no yeah do you think i should
not necessarily okay i think you should
be you okay you know i think it's
working out fine
yeah i don't know well i no i i think
that's interesting that you asked me
that because
people ask me that you know what where
do you what's the next thing or where do
you see yourself in five years and i
don't really
approach my life that way i really don't
think about those things then i feel
guilty because
like here's my five-year plan like yeah
you know
should i have a five-year plan i don't
know do you
so you don't have a five-year plan no
you have a weekly plan
i have a schedule of things that i'm
doing but everything that ends up on the
calendar
is a reflection of me i mean i'm in a
very privileged place where i have the
opportunity to
seek out things that that interest me
and pursue
my curiosity whether that's in sport or
with the podcast or other creative
outlets
and not everybody has that you know kind
of life so i'm very grateful for that
but
you know it's all about like oh this is
cool let's see what this is about rather
than like i'm working towards this thing
yeah and there's a destination and it's
going to look like that when i get there
like i don't function that way yeah
that's cool
me neither yeah i don't i don't get that
well but at the same time you do like
well you you you say these are the races
i'm going to do this year
and i'm working towards my best
performance of them so they're anchored
you're those are like the anchors and
then your life kind of orients around
that but within that there's so much
opportunity to
you know be flexible and intuitive about
your approach yeah for sure yeah
one of the things that you see in in
ultra running is
is a problem with longevity in careers
like you see athletes who come onto the
scene
they crush it they have a a window of
time a couple years where they're
indestructible they're just winning
everything in sight
and then something happens and they
can't quite
match those performances anymore i've
seen it
mostly in men time and time and time
again
and i've often thought like what is
causing that or why is that
and i'm not sure anybody knows the
answer to that but obviously you're
aware that this is the case so do you
think at all about
how you can protect
um the longevity of what you're trying
to
accomplish like do you put any effort
into that or thought
yeah i want to be doing the sport as
long as possible
and uh i mean my schedule my race
schedule four years ago would have been
an ultra every month because i love it
so much and i just wanted to do this
thing i love
and also i felt good doing it so why not
sign up for more
but have wisened a little bit
over the years to ease back on asking my
body to
go to that place so many times a year
and also
i mean i had an injury a few years ago
that
taught me to not neglect the small
things like
core work or um stretching foam rolling
like
things like that yeah i now implement
because
it's this tiny change i can do
to maybe keep me in the sport longer
yeah i think i remember when you were on
when you're on rogan he asked you about
stretching and you're like yeah i should
probably should but i don't really
so there's a change right yeah you're
growing wiser
yeah a little bit yeah but it's life's
lumps that force you to
you know make those adjustments yeah for
sure yeah
well soon the diet we'll talk about that
[Laughter]
yeah we can talk about it we'll see no
i'm not getting involved
you're doing fine i you know and are you
still like you don't know
no supplements or anything like that no
not just candy bars
yeah mostly jelly beans
jelly beans yeah the fruity fruity candy
is my favorite
and it's getting vitamins in there
somehow so yeah
and then when you're out training like
with the hydration pack
what is it it's tailwind like what is
your go-to tailwind
honey stinger and then if it's a
race i'll probably have some mashed
potatoes in my pack
um and then if it's a really long race
then it's like
any other carbs pizza burgers
pancakes uh-huh pierogies
really good mcdonald's french fries so
good
yeah the salt right yeah
yeah really any form of potato
tastes great during ultra yeah they work
well
yeah they're effective for sure um well
i'm excited
to see these races uh unfold with you
thank you it's pretty cool which uh
which shoe are you gonna wear
probably the s lab ultra three uh-huh
have you tried it
i haven't tried that one yet i've been
running in the the ultra glide the new
shoe that's about to come out
so good yeah it's great right yeah
enjoying that
i like the the scents very much too
those are what i'm wearing right now i
think
the scents ride yeah they're great uh
i need i i gotta try those s-labs though
i haven't i haven't run in those
i'm so happy you're on the team hmm
thank you i'm very happy i'm very proud
i feel
unworthy all right so i want to live up
to it you're
very worthy yeah i'm you know i was
nervous and
awkward and scared myself to talk to you
because
i have so much respect for everything
that you do and you're such a joy and a
pleasure to speak to
and uh i wish you only the best well
thank you
yeah and i look forward to spending a
little bit more time
with you and getting to know you and um
being a cheerleader for your success
thank you
yeah let's uh run some trails today i
would love to do that
my guy's here i got a lot of work to do
i don't know if i can talk talk
talk my way out of the office but i'll
see what i can do yeah they won't know
um cool so if people want to connect
with you
what's the best way for them to find you
on the internet basically if you type in
her name in google there's plenty
yeah instagram maybe yeah at ins
on instagram at courtneydewalter mm-hmm
awesome it would be great
all right well come back after these
races and and
tell me about it yeah i would love that
cool peace
[Music]
you